oh there's michael rapaport a couple of
weeks ago bowie
mentioned that his wife um can't sleep
and i'm wondering is he surprised by
that and and
has it been going on for decades because
if you had to sleep next to that [ __ ]
rotten
buffalo tooth ache don't you think she
should be frightened
you mean because she's sleeping with a
wild animal yes
i mean and and and the lack of
compassion like she should sleep with
one eye open or like with a dark gun
next to her in case he makes any
i think you should have a little bit of
compassion for gary today because
he has to get root canal uh he he
you know his teeth are a constant sorts
of problems
and now i guess some food got trapped
back there
i was asking him about it with his caps
and everything else
and uh so something happened
where uh there was uh howard i have to
disagree with you
you're you're telling me the guy that
brought his teeth
worldwide attention to give him
compassion when the day
the dentist why don't you get the
dentist on the show that has to give
this [ __ ] gorilla
root canal get the [ __ ] jackhammers
out
okay get the crane don't you think
they're gonna have to
inject him with a uh some sort of um
like with a tranquilizer gun
you know dart gun i mean the dentist the
dentist should be getting paid
extra just for having to open that big
[ __ ] mouth he needs a contractor not
a dentist
barry i don't know what my contractor
all right michael you've had your fun
things from the [ __ ] cement truck
i mean seriously you got to get a cement
truck for that
okay i don't even care what you guys say
about me because the [ __ ] pain is
excruciating and i
wouldn't i gotta try to get an
appointment sometime today
right you have no appointment yet well i
have one for tomorrow
do you floss gary of course floss water
pick
i mean i go to the dentist twice a year
way too involved
and they never caught this he said water
pick i was thinking fire hose for that
mouth
the dentist is in a sweat i think he's
bringing it that's why they have to wait
till tuesday
to uh operate on him people are flying
in he's checking his medications they
had to assemble a team
you're right and yeah it's time to get
that together we're gonna need a team
we're gonna need the greatest dentist
that
ever lived to go into that mouth get
that wheel barrel and the cement
gotta fix that crack this is like one of
those non-stop things like this
you can't chew on that side of your
mouth there's you know and
like i would like a headache i was
eating yesterday then you accidentally
chew on that side and you hit down and
then it just like reverberates through
your whole body
mm-hmm
waiting
i'm sorry to the dentist
[Music]
again